[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and this week we're
talking about live training drills in
Aikido so this is what we call the
corner drill it's a really simple drill
where we have one person locked in a
corner the other person isn't going to
encroach on them but they're going to
try to keep them from getting out of the
corner right so the one person is gonna
guard at the corner essentially yeah the
person's gonna try to get out of the
corner so I'm gonna call Josh and my in
here we're gonna go to work for you guys
okay so right now we're gonna do is we
have Josh in the corner and you notice
we have some cones set up here and
that's basically the line that Maya
won't go past so she's gonna stay
outside of the corner and go side to
side now there you could run a quarter
drill where you don't make that criteria
absolutely for sure
but this is a good drill to practice for
Josh to practice skills of working out
of this corner when Maya is not coming
in sometimes when the other person comes
in it can be kind of easier because they
give you more room to escape but you
know if Maya was waiting for a friend to
come in she might lock Josh into a
corner so he just can't escape and then
the two of them could attack John and
Josh needs to have the ability to get
out of there rather quickly so this is a
situation where mine is actually not
trying to encroach on Josh so he can't
really make good a one stay with that
but at the same time
Joshua still has the urgency to get out
so he's locked into a quarter he needs
to get out Maya won't come in so he
can't blend with her and so he's got to
find another way out at this corner so
my is gonna work on the outside of this
here she has to stay outside those cones
whole time josh is gonna try to get out
if Maya grabs a good hold of Josh then
she wins the drill
if or knocks him back and show in the
drill or if Josh if Josh gets completely
free of mines that he wins the drill
I'll say go and then you're free to go
whenever you want ready go
she's got a good job and go good job and
one more reset
very nice good all right so you can see
the basic idea of that drill is just
teaching our noggin
how to get out of a situation where it's
locked into a corner and the other
person isn't advancing anymore so mines
not advancing on Josh so he can't make
go to wha say if she was going into the
corner he might be able to watch day out
of there and a lot of Aikido movements
actually work really well for that but
in this situation she's just trying to
stagnate him so maybe a buddy could come
in or she gets a superior weapon or who
knows what but Josh needs to get out of
there so in this drill he's forced to
actually go towards her which is
generally not what we want to do in
Aikido but he's forced him to make that
movement and help me make a Buddha
was--a to skill escape the corner this
is the corner drill thanks for watching
[Music]